ouverture aujourd'hui du procès en appel
d'alexander vinik ce ressortissant russe
de 41 ans est considéré comme l'un des
pionniers des cyberattaques
il est accusé d'être le cerveau d'un
logiciel malveillant d'extorsion un
programme baptisé loki qui est au coeur
d'un bras de fer entre paris et
washington et athènes les etats unis ont
prononçé 21 chefs d'inculpation à
l'encontre d'aleksandar binic et espère
pouvoir le juger sur leur sol sans avant
qu'un à lui estime que la justice
française doit se prononcer contre cette
extradition
avec son offre unique risque à des
traitements inhumains et dégradants
alexandra vinik a aujourd'hui dans un
état psychologique grave nous demandons
d'ailleurs une expertise psychologique
pour alexander vinik alex harvey milk a
subi plusieurs grèves de la faim
sérieuse il est à l'isolément depuis
quatre ans et demi
il est donc dans un état psychologique
extrêmement difficile et nous
considérons que donc pour ces raisons il
ne saurait y avoir de renvoi d'alexander
inique en grèce pour être extradé aux
états unis
c est nous demandons à la cour d'appel
de paris de se juger compétente pour
pouvoir justement rejeté cette demande